brought to you by PlayStation view the
new live TV service now available on
your playstation over 100 channels no
annual contract game the system hey
folks Chris waters here on the front
lines at South by Southwest taking a
look at a game that's lighting up the
show floor with vibrant splashes of
blood I'm talking with himanshu about as
tez I am on true this game is a look at
pretty violet but in a kind of
aesthetically very interesting way yes
that is correct the art style of this
game is really appealing and the
response we are getting is actually a
testament to that a lot of people are
really drawn in to this visual style of
black and white with lots of blood the
striking red against the black and white
but it is that visual style they like
that sort of Aztec inspired art that it
i think is grabbing a lot of attention
and also it's a super easy game to demo
the set the demo you have set up here is
just pure combat not is correct it's not
the complete game because there's also a
colon based strategy aspect to this game
the turn-based strategy then has pockets
of real-time combat we are dumb and a
mowing the real-time combat right now
alright so tell us how it works you get
in there you've got your club with the
you know obsidian wedged in there like a
true Aztec warrior I what kind of kind
of mechanics are in play this game
focuses really well on the combos so
everyone has been able to pick up the
game and execute really complex combos
but is like we haven't had to explain
people how to actually play this game
which is it which is a blessing in
disguise right because I've walked
around here and a lot of people have to
explain the controls a lot about their
game so it's very easy to pick up and
play and the combat mechanics are very
deep so it's not just pressing a button
consistently you can like you can block
you can employ different strategies you
can collect blood raise up your blood
meter and then you have like a
superpower executed when someone is just
drawing you could hold them do a
finishing move
and what that does is give you more
blood and when you gather blood your
health increases a little so there are a
lot of these little things in the combat
that you observe and use as your
strategy when fighting lots and lots of
dudes combat systems that kind of feed
into each other and try to build that
momentum and certainly we've been seeing
you know the games been gathering some
momentum here on the show floor as
people are drawn to that iconic style
and the intuitive controls so as test
what systems is it coming out for and
when can we hope to see it on store
shelves or on digital shells probably so
it'll start out on Steam and it will
follow up on all the modern consoles
xbox one ps4 it will also come out on
the PS Vita and the end like the release
date is still to be determined could be
a year could be two years from now so
hopefully we'll get a look at more that
tactical turn-based layer of as says in
the coming months but for now it's a
good old splash of bloody good time
you